salutations distinguées en rangeant
quelques dossiers de la chaîne je me
suis aperçu que ça fait longtemps qu'on
n'a pas parlé de tour de magie et vous
savez que la magie le mentalisme sont
extrêmement liés et que je suis
également magicien du moins ça a été ma
première activité professionnelle et un
jour sur un puzzle un spectateur m'a
fait un tour et m'a bluffé avec il m'a
tenu au moins un quart d'heure leur
faire avant que je comprenne son tour
est hyper malin la personne il sapelé
alex
alex si tu regardes la chaîne mais un
commentaire en précisant l'endroit où tu
vivais comme ça ça me permettra de voir
que tu es le vrai alex et aujourd'hui je
vais vous apprendre cette astuce
histoire qui n'est pas d'embrouillés
vous précise quand même qu'après avoir
fait des recherches il s'avère que la
technique c'est une technique populaire
lui il l'avait apprise dans un magazine
genre picsou magazine pif gadget je
savais qu'il avait fait encore plus
marrer quand ils voyaient galéré à
trouver comment ils avaient quand vous
allez apprendre le secret forcément ça
va vous paraître simple à comprendre
je vais vous simulez le tour comme si
j'étais en train de vous faire pour que
vous puissiez d'abord vous rendre compte
à quel point c'est cool
vous prenez un petit paquet de cartes
vous le faites mélangés par votre
spectateurs vous lui demandez de choisir
une carte de la regarder de la remettre
où il veut dans le jeu lui-même est de
mélanger le jeu également lui-même juste
d'y penser
vous récupérez le jeu vous le regardez
un petit peu et vous êtes capable de
sortir la carte qu'il avait choisi du
jeu c'est exactement comme ça que ça se
passe il n'y a pas d'autres embrouille a
pas d'eau tarnac
tous passent grâce aux cartes que vous
avez sélectionné précieusement avant de
faire le tour
ce ne sont pas des cartes prises au
hasard ce sont que 17 des as sauf l'as
de carreau des neuf sauf le 9 de carreau
des six des cinq sauf le 5 de carreaux
et des 3 pourquoi ces cartes là je vais
vous le dire parce qu'elles ont toutes
une particularité elles sont
asymétriques exemple de cartes non
asymétrique le 8 de coeur que je le
prenne comme ça où comme ça il est
parfaitement identique
idem pour le valet de pique par contre
si on prend le set de pics comme ça et
comme ça c'est pas la même chose
il a un sens alors première étape vous
classer toutes les cartes asymétrique
d'un jeu de cartes dans un même sens
pour moi mon sens c'est de mettre tous à
l'endroit donc là on voit le coeur
centrale il est à l' endroit le 13
centrales est à l'endroit sur les cartes
comme le set de carouge le mais juste au
plus haut possible sur les cartes un peu
particulières comme le 6 2 pi qui
peuvent être la même chose pour les
trois d'ailleurs sur ainsi son 1 à 4
dans un sens et deux dans un autre sens
donc ceux qui sont le plus nombreux je
les mets dans le bon sens vers le haut
voyez pour le 3-2 pic c'est la même
chose donc vous mettez toutes les cartes
dans le même sens dans un sens précis
vous confier le jeu à votre spectateurs
et vous lui demandez de mélanger
normalement ça s'appelle un mélange la
française vous pouvez lui faire voir
comme ça vous êtes sûr qu'il fait la
même chose dit voilà tiens je te passe
le jeu tu mélanges comme ça s'il te
plaît et il le mélange vous récupérez
les cartes vous fait un petit éventail
comme ceci avec vos mains vous lui en
fait de choisir une
le spectateur va prendre une carte le
cinq de coeur currence pendant qu'il le
prend dans sa main vous aller refermer
l'éventail mais pas comme ça de la
gauche vers la droite de votre gauche
vers votre droite c'est à dire votre
index mais là
sarr ferme le paquet et vous continuez
de mouvements pour retourner le jeu lui
faire faire un demi tour et ça c'est
pendant que le spectateur regarde la
carte mais toute manière il n'y a rien à
cacher vous refaites un petit éventail
pour les dires vas-y rom et la carte où
tu veux dans le jeu le spectateur donc
remis sa carte où il veut dans le jeu et
encore une fois vous lui dites de
mélanger comme il l'a fait au départ ils
mélangent comme il l'a fait au départ et
là vous allez faire semblant avec vos
pouvoirs de magiciens de capter quelque
chose et de se dire ok je jette à carte
je vois exactement quelles cartes sait
déjà c'est une carte à double ça vous en
supplie sûr et certain et vous lui dites
je suis tellement sûr de connaître ta
cap je vais la sortir tu vas voir que ça
va être la bonne et à ce moment là vous
prenez le jeu dans les mains et sous
prétexte de chercher la carte en fait
vous allez prendre connaissance de sa
carte vous passez les cartes en revue et
elles sont toutes dans le même sens
alors comme on a fait un demi-tour tout
à l'heure maintenant tout est vers le
bas tout est vers le bas tout est vers
le bas vers le bas vers le bas vers le
bas on a bien les quatre qui sont vers
le bas et le cinq de coeur est la seule
dans le bon sens toutes les autres sont
également vers le bas ça veut donc dire
que la carte du spectateur c'est le cinq
de coeur donc vous la sortez du jeu vous
lui dites est ce que tu peux me dire
qu'elle car tu avais choisi il vous
distingue le coeur et fait bam et là
parfois les gens s'évanouissent surtout
s'ils n'ont pas mangé depuis 48 heures
en fait sinon il reste debout
une fois les hurlements de la foule
terminé pour hommes étaient cinq de
coeur dans le jeu dans le même sens que
les autres et vous êtes prêt à refaire
le tour la seule chose sur laquelle il
faut être toujours vigilant
ceci le spectateur prend la carte comme
ça la met devant lui vérifiez qu'il soit
pas en train de la tournée en vrai ça
n'arrive jamais mais je vous le dis
quand même au cas où puisque le but du
jeu c'est que la carte ne soient pas
remises dans le même sens que le paquet
donc si vous tournez le paquet et qui
tourne sa carte va falloir encore une
fois tournée paquet je vous le dis
vraiment pour information si un jour ça
arrivait pareil si jamais en mélangeant
il fait tomber les cartes ça ça m'est
déjà arrivé par contre pas de panique
vous ramassez les quatre vous ramassez
le paquet vous remettez un petit peu
dans le bon sens sous prétexte de
vérifier qu'ils manquent pas de carte et
vous dit tu sais quoi on va tout
reprendre à zéro
voilà ça change un peu ça faisait
longtemps qu'on n'avait pas fait un tour
de magie sur cette chaîne j'espère que
ça vous a plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas à nous faire savoir en laissant un
pouce en l'air à nous le faire savoir
genre il ya une équipe derrière tout ça
si ce genre de tour de cartomagie vous
plaît n'hésitez pas également à
m'envoyer un petit message en privé et
je me ferai un plaisir de vous renvoyer
vers des ouvrages spécialisés qui sont
faits par des éditeurs spécialisés dans
la prestidigitation ce sont des livres
un peu plus cher que la moyenne
ça demande du travail mais si vraiment
vous
vous m allah car thomas j c'est par là
qu'il faudra passer les livres et le
travail si jamais vous n'êtes pas
abonnés à cette chaîne je sais que ça
peut encore arriver
n'hésitez pas à cliquer ici et rendez
vous demain à 17h ciao
gala